Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Naomi, Ben, Marcus, James. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Before the main topic, let's do a fast round — where's everyone at? Keep it short.
On my side, the CARE governance framework is moving along — made good progress this week, nothing blocking.
I've been heads-down on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
Just flagging that this touches the manifest schema and validator, so loop me in when it firms up.
I've been heads-down on the manifest schema and validator. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Good point — let's do that.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Makes sense to me.
I've been heads-down on the label renderer and the validator tests. It's mostly there; I'll have the next piece up in a couple of days.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Makes sense to me.
Not much to report on the backend capability model and the provenance schema beyond steady progress. I'll flag it if that changes.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Right, that's what I meant.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
That's fair.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Sure, I can own that.
community review and the advisory process — steady. One open question I'll raise when we get to it, otherwise fine.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Q3 retro. Round-robin as always. The numbers are in the tool, but I want the human read. Dana?
My airtime went from about two-thirds to under 40%. The nudges did what I couldn't do by watching myself. That's the honest headline.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Exactly.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Let's confirm in the channel.
I speak in meetings now. Not because I changed, because the format did — pre-reads and round-robin. The silence in Q2 was a design problem, not a me problem.
Same-day on the August regression instead of four days. And I defended a design in review and survived it.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Good point — let's do that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Sure, I can own that.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Sure.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Right, that's what I meant.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Just flagging that this touches the label renderer and the validator tests, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
That's fair.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Good point — let's do that.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Let me park that and come back to it.
Dissent-before-decision is just how we work now. And the license question never reopened — we actually settled it in June with the snapshot mitigation.
Sure.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Makes sense to me.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Yeah, exactly.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Agreed, let's capture it.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Sure, I can own that.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
How does this interact with the backend capability model and the provenance schema, if at all?
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Sure, I can own that.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
That's fair.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
My one caution: don't let the tool become the point. It's a mirror. The work is still us choosing to look. But it's a good mirror.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the manifest schema and validator anyway.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sure, I can own that.
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
How does this interact with the manifest schema and validator, if at all?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Good point — let's do that.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Makes sense to me.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
That's fair.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the backend capability model and the provenance schema anyway.
Okay, yeah.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Yeah, exactly.
Makes sense to me.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Makes sense to me.
Just flagging that this touches the backend capability model and the provenance schema, so loop me in when it firms up.
Action: roll it out to the two partner districts' teams, and publish the before/after so other Alaska teams can use it.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Makes sense to me.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Right, that's what I meant.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Let's confirm in the channel.
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Sure, I can own that.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Right, that's what I meant.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the manifest schema and validator?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the the label renderer and the validator tests side, or is that covered?
Should I loop anyone else in on the community review and the advisory process side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Naomi has the follow-up on the manifest schema and validator — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.